ich melde dich 12 beichtet dass sie
geträumt habe dass ich und die personen
die ich lieber im bett waren und nach
neun monaten ein kleines kind
herzukommen zu einem neuen video lloyds
royal hat der bund wahrscheinlich warum
ich jetzt hier selbst noch der coach
schütze mein linker platz ist frei was
ist da los das liegt daran dass es so
gewissen trend gerade jetzt und zwar vor
allem auf instrumente gibt es diesen
trend so gewisse instagram pages
aufzumachen und dann gibt es andere
leute die diesen gewisse insgesamt ist
dinge zu schicken und zwar beichten und
diese seiten veröffentlichen und diese
weichen die dinge wissen seinen
öffentlich werden verdienen definitiv
das ein oder andere mal das prädikat
absolut ehren los und deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht leute nicht die stimme
argumentieren heute guckt was für ihre
lose und absolut menschlich gesehen
abstoßende beichten dass da draußen gibt
reagiert darauf und sagt dabei wie sehr
ich bei jeder einzelnen aus dem fenster
springen möchte weil wir die prozedur an
leute das war jetzt bei ich da auch hin
zu werden gibt es zwei suchergebnissen
hat natürlich den hashtags einfach weil
ich den punkt how und dann kommt sex
geschichten und da kommt die letzte uns
bei ich will zwar denkbar so lasst uns
beispiel sowieso eine christliche seite
oder sondern halt wird dann würde ich
sagen ja ich hab checken ist punkto
übrigens ich habe alle seiten verlinkt
keine entgegen die seit ihr könnt ihr
gerne abziehen gerne abonnieren schickt
uns auch beichten alter und geschlecht
hause anonym also zehnmal mehr als
komplett anonym ist schon mal nicht
schlecht ich wenn ich zwölf weißt du
dass ich geträumt habe dass ich und die
person die ich liebe im bett waren und
nach neun monaten kam ein kleines
wer ein ticket nach männlich 16 sucht
ein mädchen das gerne lust auf bilder
tausch hat und sex chat gute war ich da
auch an der stelle den finde ich super
dass du dich tatsächlich getraut hat das
auch mit uns zu teilen einfach gut weil
es doch gar nicht so leicht sich auch
schon leute und ist auch nicht leicht
über sein bedürfnis zu sprechen dass man
bilder tauschen sexcam girl mädchen
haben möchte deswegen respekt an einem
16 16 doch der britische geheimnis was
auch der erste der ganzen praktische
gehalten ich war 16 beichtet dass ich
mir gerne wünsche dass die welt
untergeht
ok ich weiblich 14 beispiel dass ich in
einem männlich 15 verliebt werden den
ich noch nie gesehen habe ich weiß nicht
wie ich ihnen sagen soll an der stelle
muss ich sagen leute eigentlich bin
bisher über diesen bereichen recht
flüssig gemacht aber das ist tatsächlich
einfach so mein leben kann falls wagen
menschen in seiner uni siegen menschen
auf der straße und man ist einfach so
straight verliebten die mit der person
gesprochen und bestritten ich bin nicht
19 beichtet dass ich den coach kritisch
habe dh ich stehe darauf wenn mädchen
barfuß oder mit socken alte weg stellen
wie zum beispiel schallplatten klassiker
ganz normal ich weiblich 13 beichtet
dass ich den richtigen jungen warte aber
die hoffnung schon irgendwie aufgebe
finde ich sehr gut an der stelle mit 13
jahren ist man nicht in seinem leben auf
jeden fall schon ein punkt angekommen wo
man sagen kann okay jetzt kommt endlich
nicht mehr so wirklich was da alles was
im leben passieren kann habe ich schon
gesehen
definitiv deute zwar regelt ob man kann
auch sinnvolle sachen einfließen lassen
wenn ihr 13 seien aber denkt euch euer
leben ist vorbei aber noch nicht gehen
oder die richtigen gefunden hat okay ich
bin jetzt 22 und zwischen 13 und 22
fühlt sich an wie beliebigkeit ein
bisschen was passiert
da habe ich meine sitzen werde wenn ich
so spiele da stimmt irgendwas nicht mehr
würde ich vielleicht mal mit irgendein
vertrauten reden oder das installieren
muss ich wirklich gestimmt heute kann
ich jetzt an der stelle nicht ganz
gezielt wollte wieso jetzt sagt was sie
denkt sich so erhält das pixel neben dem
schwimmbad übels geil ich weil ich 16
bin seit drei jahren mit meiner cousins
zusammen machte was nicht leute dann
haben wir hier an dieser stelle leute
von anderen seite die beichte ich mich
an 20 besteht dass bei mir nochmals
verengt und noch nicht mal alle türchen
offen sind nicht einfach gerne
verlängern will für mich veranstalter
bands kennt dadurch nie meine türe
aufgemacht wurde mit dieser verdammten
jetzt leute gibt die auf die natürlich
sehr christliche seite lasst uns beiden
ich werde drei cent bekomme auf gälisch
sport war immer eine direktion da muss
ich sagen wollte ist die reaktion ebenso
nicht selbst der nachvollziehen kann
dass man bei schönen autos gerade bei
stärkeren autos bei vielleicht auch
teureren autos eine besondere emotionale
reaktion zeigt wenn sich diese besondere
emotionale reaktion aber unterhalb der
gürtellinie abspielt ist da eventuell
auch irgendwas nicht ganz in ordnung
präpariert wurde wunderschöne geschichte
leute ich weiß nicht wer zum beispiel
dass ich ein werk gehen natürlich hat
noch eine politik hier ist habe ich mir
schon gedacht wieder einiges ganz gutes
zu sagen manchmal nicht unter kontrolle
perfekt es wird die meisten von euch
zuhause auszugehen dass hier einfach
eine website ist kann sagen können falls
stadt zu die kommentare leute die
natürlich zum scheint auch mal drunter
wir so was findet und
der hat einfach für tosca ja gerne